JOE LAZAUSKAS: Thanks, Eric.
And hi, everyone.
Thanks for having me here.
It's definitely an
honor to get to speak
at a place like Google.
And it's also awesome because
this gave me an excuse
to spend expensive
trip out to LA
and escape the frigid,
depressing, New York cold.
I know you guys probably
think this is cold,
but this is like
beach weather to me.
I'm going to be out there later
in, like, my "Jersey Shore"
tank top just fist pumping
on the beach in Venice.
And I'm really glad to be here
to share some of the lessons
from my book that just came out
just a week ago, with my friend
Shane Snow, who
co-founded Contently.
For those of who
don't know, Contently
is a technology company
based in New York.
We basically have a
network of over 100,000
freelance creatives
throughout the world
and a technology platform that
is essentially like Salesforce
for content, allows you
to manage your content
for all parts of your
organization, different aspects
of the customer journey,
different departments
within your org.
It makes sure all of it is
really high quality, aligned,
on brand, all that good stuff.
And what I do is
content strategy there.
I head up our content
strategy group.
So I help our
customers figure out
what stories they should tell,
because this is something
I'm really passionate about.
I'm a journalist by trade.
I had a news site that
I started out of college
that I ran before Contently.
And then I came to
Contently to figure out
how to tell our story.
It's line that
propelled our growth
from a startup with
just a few people to one
with hundreds of employees
all over the world.
And it's something
that we've seen
make a really big
impact for our clients
over the past seven years.
As the dynamics of search
and social platforms
have broken down the walls
between brands and consumers,
we've seen the power of what
can happen when a brand is
able to tell its story.
And what I want to talk about
here today is just a few
of the keys that I see to
the future of storytelling
for businesses, the things
that will separate those that
do a really good job from
those that tend to struggle
or continue to put out
product one sheets and display
ads in sheep's clothing.
And so this is a lot of
stuff that's in the book.
Eric was kind enough to
buy about 25 books that are
scattered around here today.
So please take a copy.
If there's probably
some extras, take some
and give them to a friend.
And I hope that what
I present here today
will peak your
interests a little bit.
So at Contently, we have this
mirror on our wall that says,
those who tell the
stories rule the world.
It's a Native American
proverb, and it's
something that really captures
the ethos of the company,
something we really believe, And
every presentation, everything
we do, we want to tell a story.
So I want to start with
a story here today.
And it's a story of Thomas
Edison, known to you guys
probably as a really
great inventor.
But what a lot of
people don't know
is that Edison was an
even better businessman.
He was kind of like the
Steve Jobs of his day.
And what Edison was a
really, really good at
was gathering a bunch of
engineers, understanding
what was the next
big thing that would
capture people's attention
that would really wow them.
And then bringing together
really smart people
to make those things and kind of
take all the credit after that.
And so around the turn
of the 20th century,
Edison came up with an
invention called a kinetoscope.
And what Edison realized
was that if you took still
images and moved them in rapid
succession in front of light,
you could create the
illusion of life.
You could create
a motion picture.
And whenever Edison knew
that he had a really, really
good invention, he would
build up a lot of hype.
Like Jobs, he would
pack a bunch of people
into a large auditorium.
In this case, it would
be an opera house.
And people would
come out, and they
would put on their best
blazers and suits and top hats,
their finest furs.
And they would sit in
anticipation for Edison
to come out.
And Edison would wait, and
he'd wait for them to build up,
wait for all the anticipation
to build up, and he'd come out.
I don't know if like Jobs he
would wear black turtleneck
and put his hands like this
in front of a spotlight,
but I'd like to
imagine that he did.
And so Edison came out and he
unveiled his newest invention
of the kinetoscope.
And it started to play,
and people gasped.
People ran up to the screen and
put their hands in front of it.
They couldn't believe
what they were
seeing, that it wasn't real.
And you know what they saw?
It's this.
It was garbage.
People literally
watched garbage.
This first movie was
straight-up garbage.
People put on their finest
furs, their best top hats.
They got a babysitter to go
and watch the kids at home
so that they could
watch garbage.
But the thing is they loved it.
And this led to the
launch of Hollywood.
There's 23 movies released
between 1900 and 1909;
the next decade, over 4,600.
In the '20s, nearly 7,000
films, and some of those
films were quite good.
They were hits.
But then something happened.
And the number of films
being produced in Hollywood
started to decline.
And there's a reason for that.
It's that while there's a few
really good films, most of them
were garbage.
Most of them had no narrative,
no plot, and no story.
They were just grainy footage
of a train or garbage.
And it's actually one of the
first storytelling lessons
that we'll learn, which is
that garbage stories are
only cool when
there's they're novel.
Only when that medium
first comes out
were people willing to
come in and get dressed up
all fancy to go watch garbage.
But once it stopped
being new, they
stopped wanting to
keep coming out.
And this is a pattern that we
actually see with all mediums,
with web content.
So I don't know about you
guys, but when I first
got the internet, I
got that AOL dial-up,
had that sweet serenade of
shutting off my mom's phone
line and dialing up.
GeoCities was my jam.
I was just enamored,
from a young age,
with this dynamic where
you could go and see
this information and
content that people from all
over the world were
posting, or see stuff
that your friends were posting.
And it didn't matter
if it was good or not.
I'd spent hours reading
random Xangas and LiveJournals
and GeoCities pages.
I would read the embarrassing
emo poems and confessionals
that my friends would post.
And I have to admit, I probably
posted some of those myself
as well.
Please, no one
try and find them.
I'm sure they exist somewhere.
But eventually what
we get is that that
stopped becoming novel.
And before long,
the internet became
this kind of cesspool
of garbage content being
posted onto the web.
We got bad eHow articles about
how to write bad eHow articles.
We saw this with blogs.
When the first-person
blog came out,
we had people like Bill
Simmons and Pete Cashmore
that were able to build this
giant audience without a lot
of promotion just by posting
these first-person blog
posts and essays and online.
But eventually, we just got
more and more of that crap.
We got this slew, this
cesspool of first-person blogs
and narratives.
It became harder and
harder to break through.
We saw this with infographics.
It used to be that
if you could make
an infographics in
the early 2000s,
you'd get on, like,
any blog out there.
But so many people started
creating bad infographics that
didn't communicate
information very well,
that didn't tell a story,
that by 2008, Mashable
was banning any guest post
submissions or any submissions
with infographics in them.
We saw this with Facebook.
So when brands
first got Facebook,
when first Facebook
first opened to brands,
it seemed like a miracle.
You could just
post, like this post
if you will if you hate
Mondays, and people would get
hundreds and hundreds of likes.
Brands would get a each to
30%, 40% of their audience.
But what happened is brands
kept posting that kind of crap.
And eventually people
stopped engaging with them.
It wasn't cool.
It wasn't novel
anymore that you can
interact with Tide on Facebook.
And reach dropped
to less than 2%.
We saw this with Instagram,
with Pinterest, with LinkedIn.
The same pattern is
that eventually there's
new platforms, people
are interested in it,
and it gets flooded
with so much garbage.
And this is what we
call the Edison cycle.
Technology enables a new medium.
People make garbage.
And then people
ignore the garbage.
So in conclusion,
everything is garbage.
That's the end of my talk.
[APPLAUSE]
Actually, no, there's more.
But then something
else happened.
So do you remember this chart
we had a moment ago, the garbage
chart?
Well, something
really interesting
happened after that.
Can anyone guess?
Get five free books
if you can guess it.
I think we have five extra.
AUDIENCE: Cold War.
JOE LAZAUSKAS: Cold War?
[LAUGHS] One for the Cold War.
One more guess.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOE LAZAUSKAS: Very close--
"Star Wars."
So in 1977, "Star
Wars" came out.
And it recaptured
and reinvigorated
people's imaginations with
what going to the movies
could be like.
People started to
get that feeling they
had from that first moment where
they saw Edison's film, where
you went, and it was an event.
You'd take your friends.
You'd perm up your 'fro, get
your best friend's jacket,
best bell bottoms,
You'd go again and again
and again to see "Star Wars"
because the story was so good.
It captivated you so much.
It created this incredible
sense of wonder.
And this is, in fact, where
the cycle continues in mediums,
is we see that technology
enables the new medium,
people make garbage,
people ignore the garbage.
And then with every medium,
creativity breaks through.
So that's why Shane
and I-- my co-author
likes to call this
actually the "Star Wars"
cycle, in part, because
we're huge "Star Wars" nerds.
In any medium, we'll
see that the key
is that creativity and great
stories need to break through.
And this led to the
advent of blockbusters.
And it's something that we
saw revitalize the industry,
as people started putting in the
care and effort and investment
to make better and better films.
And we see this
with all mediums.
So let's go back to web
content, by the late 2000s,
content on the web had a lot
of noise, a lot of mess in it.
And especially in financial
content, so banks,
financial brands had started
posting content on the web.
But most of it was these bad
PDFs, white papers, basically
bank brochures
re-posted to the web.
Then there is one company
called Mint that came along.
That was one of our
first customers.
And I think when we think
about brands creating content
on the web, it's a really
inspiring example because they
thought, what if we
talked about the one thing
that everyone
really cares about,
which is how to manage
your money better?
Whether you need to buy a
house, pay student loans,
just save, better manage
your credit card debt,
it's something that
matters to anyone.
They found that no one was
doing a very good job of talking
about money on the web.
So they started writing in
very colloquial language,
first person, very
visual-heavy language.
And they started amassing
millions of readers.
They put out things
like a visual guide
to the financial crisis, that
are reported all over the web.
And they're one of
our first clients
that really showed us how
brands and businesses that
told really good dynamic
stories could build
incredible relationships,
because people
were emailing Mint every day.
Thousands of people
would email Mint and say,
thank you for helping me
pay down my student debt
or pay off my car
or buy a house,
because they were making a
difference in people's lives
through the stories
they were telling.
And this is
something that we see
is that the science
of storytelling
actually shows that great
stories build relationships.
Great stories make us care.
Over the last 10 years,
a lot of new research
has come out that shows
that a strong connection
between storytelling and the
chemical oxytocin in our brain.
For a while, we didn't
know much about oxytocin.
We just knew it was something
that was released when mothers
would be close to their babies.
But what we have seen
of late is research
that shows that when we
engage with really, really
good stories, when we are
captivated by a story,
it actually releases
this empathy drug
oxytocin in our minds
that makes us care more
about the person that's
telling us the story,
be it the protagonist, the
brand that's telling it to us.
It builds a connection between
us and the person telling it.
And research has shown that
storytelling can break down
barriers to foster
compassion, tolerance,
and respect for differences.
It's shown that it can
build those interpersonal
relationships and that
sense of connectedness.
So we think about
this modern world,
where that barrier between
businesses and individuals
and the rest of the world
has been broken down,
where we no longer have
a means of just having
someone's captivated intention.
But we have to earn
it every second
because we have this magical
device buzzing in our pocket,
beckoning us for our attention
and with thousands of stories,
that you need a really
compelling narrative
to build those relationships
with people and make them care.
And as human beings,
we are absolutely
programmed for stories.
When we hear a story,
the neurons in our brains
fire at five times
that capacity.
It illuminates the
city of our mind.
And we store information
so much better.
And that's what's led to the
rise of this thing called
content marketing,
which is essentially
the practice of a
brand telling its story
to engage with people, to build
relationships with the folks
that it wants to sell to.
But this doesn't have
just to do with marketing.
It has to do with
all the relationships
that we have as human beings,
with the relationships that we
have as a leader with the
people in our company,
as a team member with the
other people on our team.
So when we tell our story,
we're able to draw people
in and build empathy
between us and them.
And we really believe that
the businesses of the future
will figure out how to
tell breakthrough stories,
or they're going to fail,
because there's really
no other option if you
want to actually gain
people's attention and
a place in their minds.
And so we think about
the three keys that
will lead to great storytelling
by businesses and leaders
and everyone else in the future.
Telling those
breakthrough stories
that goes above and
beyond just the garbage
status quo of a
given medium is key.
But there are other things
as well that we think
will have a really big impact.
Next story I want to
tell is of Netflix.
So in 2008, Netflix acquired
the rights to "House of Cards."
Everyone thought they
were crazy at the time
because everyone said, Netflix,
you're a technology company.
Why are you spending
$100 million on a show?
But "House of Cards"
was a really big hit.
Next they came out with
"Arrested Development."
Everyone was like,
OK, that makes sense.
"Arrested Development"
was a big cult classic.
People loved it.
But then they came
out with a show
called "Orange is
the New Black,"
and people started to scratch
their heads because there
was no one famous in
"Orange is the New Black."
There is no
Kevin-Spacey-type figure,
who obviously wouldn't do so
well today, but at the time,
was extremely popular, in
"Orange is the New Black."
In fact, the biggest star in
"Orange is the New Black,"
the biggest name, was this guy.
And no one was actually going
to go start watching a show
to see this guy.
But the thing that
Netflix knew--
I'm just going to leave
this up for a second.
The thing that Netflix
knew is that they
had so much data about their
audience's viewing habits.
So Netflix is
obsessed with data,
with tracking how
people watch things,
the succession in which
they'll watch shows,
their finish rate on shows,
their re-watch rate on shows,
and the interlap
between when people
watch one show or another.
Where is there a
correlation between watching
x-show and y-show?
How do people discover
shows within Netflix?
What are the things
that will prompt
them to start
watching a new show
and then keep
watching that show?
With "Orange is the
New Black," Netflix
needs something pretty unique.
So through all their
data, they knew
that certain viewers really
loved any shows or movies
with women-led ensembles.
And they knew there was a big
overlap between those viewers
and people who watch "Weeds."
"Weeds" was one of the most
popular shows on Netflix,
one of the best gets they'd ever
gotten when they licensed it
from Showtime.
It was constantly in the
most popular in Netflix.
They saw people watching
it all the way through,
calling out for work for
12 hours on a Tuesday
to just sit back
and watch "Weeds"
and maybe smoke up
a little themselves.
And they also knew
that those people
were very likely to
watch a show that was
prompted to them by Netflix.
So there are
certain viewers that
took Netflix flicks
recommendations very seriously
and would watch a
show unprompted.
So they saw there's this
intersection with "Orange
is the New Black," which
a women-led ensemble, that
was started by the same show
runner, Jenji Kohan, as "Weeds"
and would succeed
well with viewers
that were prompted by
Netflix recommendations
to watch this show.
So they pushed it out to that
target audience of people,
and they were able
to get "Orange
is the New Black" to essentially
go viral with these viewers.
People just watched it
all the way through.
They posted on Facebook,
on Twitter about it.
And "Orange is the
New Black," which
was a much smaller investment
than "House of Cards"
was, was a huge success
and actually paid off
in three months, helping Netflix
earn over 630,000 subscribers,
more than "House of Cards"
or "Arrested Development"
had for them.
And this is a
formula that Netflix
has repeated over and over,
with "Stranger Things,"
with "13 Reasons Why."
And while 35% of
network shows get
renewed after the first
season, 70% of Netflix
shows get renewed, and
that's because this data
and technology power that
Netflix has gives them
double the advantage.
And so we think about the
future of brand storytelling,
of content marketing.
I truly believe that human
creativity will always be key.
I think robot
writers are getting
really good at doing
things like writing up
game recaps from basketball
games or baseball
games or any financial reports.
But when it comes to
telling human stories,
I think that humans will
always win in that capacity
because we're able
to tell our story,
and we're able to use that to
connect with people in a way
that robots or AI can't.
So I think that will always
be a constant in storytelling
and the quality of brand
storytelling out there.
But I do believe that
technology has the capacity
to help us really understand
what the people we want to each
want to see, what's going to
engage them the most, what's
going to make them call
off of work all day
and sit down and
watch what we put out
or read the articles
we put out, or engage
with what we post out on Twitter
and Facebook and LinkedIn?
And while right
now what we see is
that most people in
the industry are just
using a little bit of technology
to help them figure out
what their audience
actually wants,
what they'll engage with.
The smartest people
in the industry
are using the first-party
data they have available,
the amazing slew of search
and social tools that we
have available, many of
them put out by Google,
to understand what our
audience really wants.
And they're riding the
crest of that wave.
And that's why I really
believe the second key will
be taking advantage of
that technology advantage
to tell great stories.
And for my third
and final key, I
want to tell the story
of a young Kevin Costner.
He's in a field.
He's kind of looking
confused and sultry.
And he hears a voice, if you
build it, they will come.
And they did come.
But there's one problem.
They were ghosts.
And so what does this have
to do with content marketing
and brand storytelling?
Well, right now we have
seen that [INAUDIBLE]
last year's show that 5% of
all branded content put out
gets 90% of the attention.
And so essentially,
a lot of brands
are creating content, but
very few are being successful.
And that's because so many
folks see creating content
as the ultimate goal.
They create a blog.
They create content.
They publish that content.
And they just expect
people to magically come.
They expect it to work.
But usually, they don't.
And if they do, it might just
be some bots or some ghosts.
And while content spend across
the marketing industry is up,
content strategy is flat.
Less than 40% of marketers
in B to B and B to C
have a documented
content strategy.
It's self-sabotage.
And this is something
that we're really
obsessed with at Contently
is creating and implementing
a methodology and
a content strategy
for every single client
that we work with.
And we actually think there's
a simple formula for building
an audience that can help
marketers and brands really
understand the cycle of
content creation and content
optimization that they
need to go through.
And to explain that, I want to
go back to the 16th century,
to 1500 AD, to the
advent of mass media.
So during the
Italian Renaissance,
it was a flourishing time
of culture, information.
And there was the first
mass media publication.
It was called the
[? "Ivicci." ?] It was
essentially the TMZ of its day.
And so what would happen is
you would have these gossip
writers, and they would
go out to the churches,
to the markets, and they
would gather the day's gossip.
And they would come back,
and they would print it
up using the printing press.
It was a new invention
that came out in the time.
And so they would
painstakingly go and print up
these newsletters of the day,
these gossip newsletters using
the printing press.
And then they'd
go out and they'd
distribute it all around town.
But there's
something interesting
that started happening.
So there's the [? "Ivicci" ?]
writers using the printing
press.
Then some other
writers said, hey,
I bet we can beat
the printing press
people to market if we just hand
write our gossip newsletters.
So they started hand writing
the gossip newsletters.
But then something happened.
They started getting
their heads chopped off.
Because it turned
out that people
really didn't like it when you
talked about who is bribing who
and who was sleeping with who.
There was a lot of
gossip writers getting
their heads chopped off.
So big reason for that is
they'd put their name on it.
It would be "The Daily
Gossip" by Antonio.
So what they did
instead, started
taking their name off it.
And the people who were
doing the printing press
started hand writing
as well because they
realized it was faster.
And the gossip
newsletter started
to flourish because
they'd go out,
and they'd do it in
the dead of night
so they wouldn't get
their heads chopped off.
No one knew they were
posting it there.
And this tells us one thing,
which is that strategy matters.
How you publish it is as
important as what you publish.
Just because there's a
new way of doing things,
a new technology that allow
you to put it out there,
doesn't mean it's
necessarily going to succeed.
And it's a deeper
pattern that we actually
see throughout
all forms of media
that have succeed throughout
time when folks are trying
to build an audience,
which is that you go out,
and you start creating content.
You have a hypothesis
for what's going to work.
So let's print out
some gossip newsletters
using the printing press.
Then let's engage people.
Let's go out, distribute
it around town in daylight,
and then optimize.
So what did they figure out?
It was too slow.
So next, try hand writing
it, put your name on it,
engage, go out, post it
around town, and optimize.
Oh, shit, we're getting
our heads chopped off.
So what did they
figure out next?
Take the name off
it, engage, go out
and distribute it in the
dead of night, then optimize.
You keep your head.
Everyone's happy.
You have a successful
newsletter.
To illustrate how this
has happened again
throughout history, I want to go
to 1851, my hometown, New York,
the Lower East Side.
And this was the start
of, the advent of,
the big mass-market newspaper.
Everyone who is anyone,
anyone who was anyone
had a newspaper at this point.
And there was essentially two
big rivals in the newspaper
market at the time in New York.
There is Joseph Pulitzer
of the "New York World"
and Andrew Hearst of
the "New York Journal."
And at this time, the printing
press had gotten pretty good.
It was a really efficient, good
piece of technology to use.
You couldn't beat
someone to print
by hand writing a newspaper.
Printing press was great.
So reporters would go out.
They'd gather today's news,
bring it back, print it up
in the newspaper.
And then they would give
it to these chain-smoking
11-year-olds to go out and
hand out to people as they
were getting on the subway.
They'd gawk, extra,
extra, read about it.
And what they found is
because the only way
to really get to sell newspapers
and get in people's hands
was to have as sensational
headlines as possible,
something you'll
probably find familiar
if you've been on
Facebook lately.
So it'd be things like, "Woman
Survives Mad Leap" and "War
is Coming."
But then this journalist, one
of my favorite people in history
came along and proposed a better
way to tell these stories.
Because at the time,
what the "New York World"
and "New York Journal" really
wanted was loyal subscribers.
They want people who would
get the newspaper delivered
to their house every day, have
a sustained model, instead
of having to go and
compete for sales just
by having chain-smoking
11-year-olds hawking newspapers
at subway stations.
And Nellie Bly was
a young journalist.
She came in to Joseph
Pulitzer's office.
And she asked for
a job that was seen
by most as only a job
for men at the time.
But she was a brilliant
woman, incredibly courageous.
And what she
proposes is that she
wanted to get locked up in a
mental hospital for two weeks
and document everything
that was happening inside.
And so Joseph Pulitzer said OK.
She went.
She got locked up.
And she wrote everything she
could about the atrocities
inside the mental hospital.
Joseph Pulitzer got her out.
They published a serial story
about all the atrocities
in the New York
mental health system.
It led to mental health reform
inside of New York state
and then eventually
across the country.
But even more importantly
for Joseph Pulitzer,
it led to a great
degree of loyalty
for the "New York World."
People started subscribing.
And this teaches
us a lesson, which
is that where content is
everywhere, as it is today,
go deep, tell bigger
stories, tell better stories.
Tell stories that differentiate
you from the next website
out there.
That gimmicks are fleeting, but
quality always builds loyalty.
And again, we see
the flywheel pattern.
They started
creating content that
was just sensational headlines.
They would have the
chain-smoking 11-year-olds
go and hawk it all over
New York subway stations.
They'd optimize because
there was no loyalty.
So then they started
creating better stories,
deep, investigative stories.
They engaged people, had the
chain-smoking 11-year-olds hawk
the newspapers all over town.
And they optimized.
They got subscribers.
They got a better
business model.
And this led to the biggest
newspaper empires and media
empires in the country.
Andrew Hearst eventually
adopted this model
and now has this glimmering
glass tower in New York.
Joseph Pulitzer took the lessons
that he learned and started
Columbia Journalism School.
And this eventually
trickled down
to all these different trades.
It wasn't just mass
newspapers that
were extremely successful,
but verticalized magazines,
and under Hearst's empire,
in fashion, in news,
and economics.
And finally, I want
to show how this has
applied during the digital age.
I want to tell the
story of Upworthy.
I know we often
derive Upworthy today.
But there's a lot we
can learn from its rise
into the fastest-growing
media company in history.
So in 2012, Upworthy
came out, and they
had a simple idea,
which is that there
was all this awesome
content that was out there,
really inspiring
stories on YouTube that
basically had been thrown away.
It had really incomprehensible
titles and metadata.
It wasn't really searchable
or findable by anyone.
And they thought, what
if we take that garbage--
it's actually pretty
good-- and repackage it
in a nice package, different
headlines, very shareable,
very shareable article
format and then
distribute it out there?
Test it a bunch
of different ways
on Facebook, through Facebook
ads, just a few dollars each,
and figure out which packaging
worked best, which headline,
which hero images, et cetera.
And then they would optimize.
They'd test all these different
ways of getting it out there.
They'd find the winner.
And then they'd send
it to as many people
as possible through organic
and paid Facebook distribution.
And then, over time, they would
figure out better and better
ways to package content.
They'd figure out what types of
videos they could find or make
worked really well,
really inspired people.
They'd go and they test it 25
different variations, at least,
every story.
And they'd optimize.
And then they'd figure
out even better packaging,
the one with the
dinosaurs and the ribbons.
They'd engage people through
an email newsletter list
that they built up.
And they were able to optimize.
They were able to build
a huge business out of it
because they got a huge
audience that they built up
on Facebook and via their
email lists, people who
loved these inspiring stories.
And this allowed
Upworthy to become
the fastest-growing
media company in history,
to greatly outpace "Business
Insider" and "Huff Post"
and other fast-growing
media giants of its time.
Now, eventually, Upworthy
stopped figuring out
how to optimize
and do things that
were passed the click-bait
headlines that Facebook cracked
down on.
But nonetheless,
this cycle worked,
this pattern worked
extremely well for them.
And that's because
they were able to crank
the flywheel faster
than everyone else.
Other folks out there were
testing different headline
variations.
But Upworthy was doing it in
a way where they are committed
to doing it at rapid speed, to
A/B test as fast as they could,
and optimize faster
than everyone else.
And while Upworthy
has faded away--
I mean, they still have
a pretty good audience
of 20 million
readers each month--
we've seen other digital
publishers copy this model.
And this teaches us that the
faster you crank the flywheel,
the better it's going to work.
And as marketers, as
people want to tell stories
to build audiences, we need to
test and crank that flywheel
as fast as possible.
And if we do, we
will get the kind
of insights that allow
us tell the stories
that our audience will
really love and engage with.
And that's why I
believe right now
we are entering a golden
age for all content types.
The ability to use technology
to tell incredible stories
to figure out what
our audience wants,
to measure the performance
of those stories
and optimize continuously over
time has never been greater.
As an individual creator,
you have so many tools
to go out there and create
incredible interactive data
visualizations, to create
snowfall style stories,
to create quick motion
graphic video, even if you're
someone like me, who isn't a
great coder or a programmer
or even a great videographer.
The tools we have out there
are just so tremendous.
And that the marketer of today
is really today's director.
But let's not be the
garbage director.
Let's do content marketing
that breaks through.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So the first
question that I wanted to ask
was around the challenges today.
And so what I mean
by that is every day
I meet different kinds of
people that will tell me
some spiel along the lines
of I want to tell my story,
but I feel like it's
already been told.
And to some extent, that might
be true, if you've studied
or read Campbell.
But would you have
any words of advice
or point us in the right
direction of like how
do you approach that?
Like, how do you get past
that mental hurdle of I
want to say something.
I feel like what I
have to say is unique.
But it's already been told.
JOE LAZAUSKAS: I'd say
that, especially if you're--
you have a business, right?
There's a chance you
started it for a reason that
is unique to you, that
hasn't been said before.
You have a perspective on
the industry, something
you're passionate about, that
other people haven't said
or haven't thought of before.
Like, for us, it
was this simple idea
with Shane and or
co-founder, Joe,
is that Shane was a student
at Columbia Journalism School.
He graduated 26 years old, saw
that all these different really
talented writers around
him were looking for work,
couldn't find work,
couldn't figure out
how to make a website
to get freelance work
because the recession was
just destroying digital media
all over the place.
Our other founder, Joe,
was a young [INAUDIBLE]
in Vegas, who really couldn't
find any writers to create
content for his blog, because
he saw that becoming really
important with the
increase in search traffic
and the advent of social media.
And they came
together to basically
to create a company to
bring those two together.
That's like a unique brand
story that no one else
had told before and is
incredibly compelling.
Our sales people tell it
in most every meeting.
We also had a unique
perspective on the role
that content and
storytelling could
play in helping brands build
relationships with people.
I think most
businesses will find
that they have a similar story,
a perspective that they have,
what they believe is coming in
the future for their industry
that they can talk about.
This is especially
true in B to B, right?
It's kind of hard to be a
thought leader in cereal.
I'm not sure what you can really
say if your Captain Crunch
or Count Chocula.
At that point,
you seem to create
more entertaining content
that people will really like.
But if you're in any sort
of specialized industry,
particularly B to B, you should
have something unique to say
or some perspective on where
the industry is headed.
And that's what you
should leverage.
You should look at your
audience, what they're
searching, the questions
they're asking,
and then figure out
how can I tell stories
that answer that
question in a way
that no one else has before.
And the biggest
thing is you just
have to get out there
and start trying things.
So many brands want
to just sit there
and wait for the perfect
opportunity to come along.
But the thing is, is
that, if someone else has,
or if you're looking
for a case study that--
I think Seth Godin said this.
If you're looking for
a case study that's
come out about what
you want to do,
chances are you're going to
be too late at that point,
because you're just going
to be the "me too" person.
You're going to be
that brand that's
jut saying something that
someone else has already said.